this is big Jordan J Hamm brother mister
who's been doing drugs let's see him J
hammies oh [ __ ] are those rats audio
come again god I can't get her stay in
actual rats do you say the Rat King
let's see him rat-a-tat-tat he's going
through some [ __ ] hey come out he's off
the Oh rats do you like him I do bro
he's getting that [ __ ] the lords
massage having two rats running running
your shoulder that'd be Satan's massage
the Lord massages - pigeons [ __ ]
dude rats are freaking bunnies in
disguise bro that's the old that's what
the old saying you know they're not
there this [ __ ] Satan mice of the
underworld dude they can [ __ ] standing
up bro and you're strong ones can [ __ ]
on one leg some know martial arts shout
to splinter there's the things like rats
dude they carry so many diseases fun
funny you know there's more rats in the
United States and our people but imagine
this though and that's not true that's a
nice try though no watch the rats
documentary huh
the rats documentary you believe that
stuff it's propaganda now you can't
write on that it is propaganda huh yeah
how many rats are there you are
unbelievable how you made it through
school Derek on
come on bro yeah my bad bro you know I
like to stereotype that you know say no
I look right I assume kappa yeah who
knows if any of us made it through
school
they mean Catalonian was a degrees in
here but whatever stereotype you're
running a fever that's the only degrees
you [ __ ] god boy me Academy only
people with diplomas breath okay you
were indeed keep touching me dude
dear will you tell us something chin
over here brow fact there's a billion of
them on the planet China I believe to
have more than 2 billion rats well that
doesn't make sense there's a zillion
there's billions of them on the planet
with trying to believe to have through
to bill also there's more than humans
can look at the fact he who Gould how
many rats are there in the middle of the
freeway out here oh man I'm gonna say
this how hard would it be to have so
much disease in your body and still show
up to work every day making it through
the pipes looking for the cheese smiling
occasionally there's some videos where
they smile yeah I've seen can you
imagine that you just be loaded down
with Ebola a black body ate holy a black
plague holy Oh syphilis syphilis herpes
herpes gonorrhea gonorrhea aid say
capital aids chicken pox chicken pox and
you're not even a [ __ ] chicken and
you wake up every day the flu with all
the flu the bird flu the bird ladies
they don't have that yeah I met imagine
having mad town not being a cow and just
being mad unbelievable yeah rats dude
they're survivors that's what I'm saying
bro so that we this guy as everyone is
Nana Mae
yeah they're the [ __ ] Beyonce's bro
these are the Li no Jerry no Jamie
Knowles or whatever that lady's name is
only Knowles Oh Kelly knows what she do
these days Beyonce was like see you
losers
Oh Kelly still sings what was this guy's
question am i doing I'm doing okay
brother
and I respect a man there look they do
their best dude you know I like that you
have clean rats I'll give you that yeah
mm-hmm not now probably I probably put
the rats down go go talk some real
humans though man just kind of feel your
way out there maybe a nice young lady to
help you watch some rats down the road
okay yeah there's cat lady's in that
that doesn't end well for them they get
very lonely
then there's rat boys that also doesn't
end well rats angsty you've got rats in
your apartment yeah your rats you had no
one to talk to watching reruns of
Animaniacs and [ __ ] get sad bro you
start having junior rats in your [ __ ]
apartment that's insane bro we start
having second-generation rat yeah if
you're dealing with the second third
generations of rat such a little yeah
tighten up you got to get us a Gore you
got to get a you know you got to take go
for a couple of walks or something we'll
find like a chilly place in your buyers
I want to put the cheese puffs down
[ __ ] quit watching Teen Mom and get
and go meet some ladies now I bet this
guy's a fine-ass chick dude got chicks
love guys that have animals like
interesting pets agree for the most part
rats i press this one just listen I'm
putting my detective hat on it's
probably you know you know what you know
there's no woman in that apartment there
easily could be a [ __ ] beautiful hot
chick behind one of this and a little
rats
kidnapped nation that's though they're
survivors I'm taking this Lake myself
only cuz I want to show off my shirt
that I've worked today yeah I like you
do thank you
it's a nice shirt it's a nice shirt do
my someone got me this one time
really yeah oh yeah
lake monsters dog I'll see you in deep
right field dude hell yeah Pass for the
parents park that sorry these two make
me play yeah you know your shitty has
sports they put you in [ __ ] the
outfield in Pop wanna oh yeah in Little
League
way out field I'm working okay I
remember one inning no one get out there
every now and then one of the coaches
would throw it out there to me so I
could do something Brad McGowan had no
idea the game was over by
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]